Venezuela migración narcotráfico y medio
ambiente todos temas centrales del
esperado encuentro entre los presidentes
de Estados Unidos y Colombia con
respecto a las sanciones a Venezuela
Gustavo Petro resaltó la hoja de ruta
para el levantamiento de las penalidades
no se condicionó digamos quedó planteado
sobre la mesa
una estrategia que es hacer primero
elecciones y después levantarse
sanciones o
paulatinamente en la medida en que se va
cumpliendo una agenda una agenda
electoral se vaya también paralelamente
levantando progresivamente sanciones
Petro reaccionó además a la pregunta
sobre una posible mediación entre
Miraflores y la Casa Blanca No yo no soy
mediador biden agradeció a su homólogo
latinoamericano Por recibir a miles de
migrantes venezolanos en Colombia
minutos antes en el despacho oval
intercambiaron un tema siempre candente
entre ambos países el narcotráfico Petro
quien afirma que la guerra contra las
drogas ha fracasado pidió lanchas
embarcaciones y drones para frenar el
flujo de drogas Washington insiste en la
erradicación forzada de los cultivos
pues son más de 200.000 las hectáreas
sembradas en Colombia en 2021 según
Naciones Unidas la protección del medio
ambiente no quedó fuera de la reunión
juntos Colombia y Estados Unidos están
liderando un esfuerzo para enfrentar el
cambio climático he estado trabajando
durante mucho tiempo hacemos lo correcto
para hacer un compromiso de 500 mil
millones de dólares para lidiar con la
preservación de la amazonía
Gustavo Petro intercambió con baile en
sus planes sobre su proyecto de paz
total un proceso que conlleva el
levantamiento de órdenes de captura a
líderes Rebeldes y criminales buscados
por Estados Unidos